I'm very excited to announce that Megan
and myself had a baby boy because the
sweetest temperament he's really
[Music]
his name means genuine and bold he
started crawling at six months old and
now we're hearing the nearly nine month
old eats organic baby food prepared by
Meghan herself
the little Sussex is definitely a
mini-me of Harry with his ginger hair in
a smile they have to have security they
are the most famous celebrities Royals
on the planet at the moment we
understand that we the British taxpayer
are still paying for certainly the
cautery of British security officers
that they have with them all the time
our team has one nanny caring for him in
Canada as for Archie's relationship with
the cousins well let's just say they
didn't really hang out much before Mixit
but smiland is saying that they will be
invited back for the Queen's Birthday
parade and key milestone events family
weddings for example so I think we will
see them again on that palace balcony it
just won't be as frequently as we've
been used to seeing them
[Music]